would you like to have a discussion or
would you like to interrupt and be
contentious I'm trying to listen like to
be arrogant and not hear anyone hear
people say you're making you keep
possible you're hurting you're you're
causing dysfunction in the world so or
you're going to have an intellectual
discussion because like I don't
understand no I understand exactly you
said you said there's no definition of a
human right you really don't people who
understand and empathize with other
people when they say hey man you're
really making me uncomfortable and
you're you're making my life worse yeah
legally that's irrelevant practice on
here they don't make references to the
[ __ ] law man but that's what matters
no it's not like yeah it is dude I'm
literally autistic okay I can understand
other people's feelings better than you
apparently really how would you know
that imagine if I run up and I'm a real
big jerk to you kind of like you are
right now let me finish my friends
without a law let me run up and call
someone a [ __ ] that's hate speech
first off I wouldn't use that language
you could be fined for hate speech